vamos ya con la economía aquí en directo
a América de France 24 tenemos para ello
nuestra compañera Daniela Blandón
Daniela bienvenida Muchas gracias y
vamos a empezar hablando de la segunda
mayor Tabacalera del mundo que fue
sancionada por hacer negocios
precisamente con Corea del Norte Pues sí
se trata de la British American tabaco
que acordó pagar a la justicia
estadounidense 635 millones de dólares
tras reconocer que violó las
prohibiciones de comercio con Corea del
Norte El fabricante de marcas de
cigarrillos como la que strike y Newport
vendió productos a Corea del Norte entre
2009 y 2017 a través de maniobras con
las que defraudó inclusive instituciones
financieras para que procesaran estas
transacciones según el departamento de
Justicia los cargos son conspiración
para infringir las sanciones impuestas
al régimen de pyongyang y fraude
bancario
Esta es la sanción más grande sobre
Corea del Norte en la historia del
departamento de justicia y una
advertencia a las empresas de todo el
mundo sobre los costos y las
consecuencias de violar las sanciones de
Estados Unidos
responsabilizar a los infractores
corporativos es una prioridad importante
para nosotros
y le tengo dos datos adicionales el
primero se dice que el líder norcoreano
Kim Jong es un fumador empedernido y
aparece frecuentemente en la prensa
local con un cigarrillo en sus manos y
el segundo que Rusia y China vetaron el
año pasado un impulso que estaba
haciendo Estados Unidos para que el
consejo de seguridad de Naciones Unidas
prohibiera las exportaciones de tabaco a
Corea del Norte
a todos estos cigarrillos de la American
ya sabemos De dónde vienen por lo menos
Bueno vamos a seguir de momento en
Estados Unidos porque allí siguen
también los coletazos de la reciente
crisis bancaria
registro hoy una estrepitosa caída
cercana al 50% en su acción en Wall
Street 24 horas después de que publicara
sus resultados trimestrales en ellos
anunció que sus clientes sacaron más de
100 mil millones de dólares en depósitos
así como un drástico recorte de personal
para reflejar la magnitud de su colapso
antes de la crisis por la quiebra del
silicon Valley Bang en marzo pasado la
acción de Republic Bank llegó a
cotizarse a 120 dólares ahora vale menos
de 10 dólares ahora esta corrida de
depósitos es una situación que aqueja en
general a la mayoría de bancos de este
país en el primer trimestre JP Morgan
fue el único de los grandes que lo subió
en apenas 2% entre tanto bajaron en Bank
of America y en City Club y también en
nosotros gigantes en otras entidades
financieras más pequeñas la reducción de
estos depósitos oscila entre el 3% y
casi el 2% Como por ejemplo en Western
unions quiere decir que la gente está
sacando la plata de los bancos porque se
siente muy nerviosa por lo que está
ocurriendo es normal Daniela es normal
vamos ahora con otra famosa cadena
estadounidense de restaurantes que
revive en Rusia de quien se trata pues
mire los antiguos restaurantes KFC
volvieron a abrir sus puertas pero con
otro nombre ahora los locales volvieron
a funcionar como rostex recordemos que
tras la guerra en Ucrania cada FC tuvo
que salir de Rusia pero le transfirió
los derechos de franquicia a la firma
rusa Smart Services que ahora controla
100 restaurantes lo que llama la
atención Es que como lo ven en las
imágenes la nueva cadena rosex mantiene
los colores rojo y negro distintivos de
Kfc y blanco también y una apariencia
corporativa bastante similar inclusive
algunos de los platos tradicionales se
seguirán vendiendo solamente que con
otros nombres
el menú seguirá siendo el mismo de hecho
dos nombres icónicos de Kfc serán
reemplazados en rostics vox Master se
convertirá en rosster y Twister se
convertirá en chef roll al mismo tiempo
el sabor de estos productos y la forma
en que se preparan serán exactamente
iguales solo cambiarán los nombres todo
lo demás recetas menús precios todo lo
que ahora pueden ver en más de 1000
restaurantes que afc en funcionamiento
también lo verán en nuestro restaurante
rostics
cerramos Daniela con Los indicadores los
principales índices de Wall Street
sufrieron sus caídas más profundas en lo
que va del mes después de que el Ferrer
public Bank regional reavivara el
nerviosismo sobre la salud del sector
bancario y en medio también de una
semana repleta de informes financieros
vamos a escoger algunos de los más
importantes hoy el turno fue para
Microsoft que cerró en rojo mientras el
mercado esperaba sus resultados que
terminaron sorprendiendo y se disparó
después del cierre de la bolsa sus
ingresos subieron un 7% anual en el
primer trimestre
52.900 millones de dólares seguimos con
alfa beta que informó una ligera caída
anual en las ventas de anuncios en el
primer trimestre hasta los 54 mil
millones de dólares también se
conocieron cifras de las grandes cadenas
de comidas Como por ejemplo Chipotle que
elevó ventas en 17% y McDonald's que lo
hizo en casi 13% en una señal de que los
consumidores siguen comiendo fuera del
hogar pese a los temores sobre recepción
yo todos los días tengo hambre para tu
información
Muchas gracias por esta Crónica
económica seguimos ya con directa
[Música]